with the queen's approval and agreement  the statement says the duke of york's  military affiliations and royal  patronages have been returned to the  queen the duke of york will continue not  to undertake any public duties and is  defending this case as a private citizen  as we know where civil proceedings are  underway uh allegations relating to  prince andrew and miss defray which  we've been hearing a lot about over  recent days well the  latest is that with the queen's approval  the duke of york's military affiliations  also his royal patronese have been  returned to her majesty and the duke of  york will continue not to undertake any  public duties and is defending this case  as a private citizen as we know he's not  been carrying out any public duties now  for some time and that won't change  while that case is underway